Yezo deer meat rice curry
[music] I
'll wait for tomorrow Hashiri-
san, you can eat that, so
what's up
[music]
Sapporo beer day construction gray
ano
janjan bring it 5 a
Ah yes,
do you know Sapporo also has a beer factory?  There
is a samurai named Hisanari Murahashi who made it on
Agoda. He fought against Toshizo Hijikata in the war. It
was the space of the new government
.
There was an image of the city, and we
talked about how it would be if we were still alive Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
I saw a [ __ ] in the ocean
[music]
Man shrinks when it's cold I know it stretches
and shrinks Don't talk about size  Okay, let's
go home, the Shinbo course is over, the
proprietress is waiting for me in the room, generation tax,
Kammer Goto